[موسيقى]
إن العمل الفني الذي قمت بإنشائه هو
عملية ممتعة للغاية لأنه
كان لابد من إنشاء لوحة خاصة أصبحت
لوحة قماشية الخاصة بي وهذه اللوحة مصنوعة من
سبيكة ألومنيوم مقاومة للقمر ومقاومة للفضاء
وبداخلها ذهب وخضعت لستة أشهر من الصرامة
الاختبارات وهي مصنوعة من مادة متشابهة جدًا
صنعها أنف الصاروخ
، وإذا فكرت في الأمر ،
يجب أن يمر أنف الصاروخ
بسرعة عالية جدًا
ودرجة حرارة عالية جدًا ثم درجة حرارة شديدة البرودة
،  يجب أن نفكر في حقيقة
أن القمر نفسه هو بيئة غير عادية ،
إنه بيئة قاسية وغير مضيافة للغاية
، تزيد درجة حرارته عن 123 درجة مئوية في النهار وتصل إلى 200 درجة مئوية تحت الصفر في
الليل ، وهذا فرق كبير في
درجة
الحرارة وهذا في واحد
يوم قمري واحد يستمر يوم قمري واحد أسبوعين على الأرض
الآن ما يعنيه ذلك هو أن
كل شيء على القمر سيستمر
يومًا قمريًا واحدًا فقط في
أسبوعين  لقد تم تدميرها لأنها
لا تستطيع تحمل درجات حرارة أقل من
200 درجة مئوية ، واضطررت إلى استخدام
آلة نقش بالليزر لنقش العمل الفني
في هذه اللوحة ، وليس من السهل إنها
عملية صعبة للغاية
، فالعمل الفني نفسه عبارة عن صورة قلب
لها امرأة و  رجل في المنتصف
يحتضنه ويقصد به
ترمز إلى التوحيد وإعادة
الاتصال بالبشرية
ومن ثم حوله من المفترض أن يستحضر
ما أعتبره الإنسانية
وهي فكرة العمل الذي سيثير
الحب والتعاطف بأعلى درجاته
إن الرسالة التي أحاول إرسالها إلى
العالم من خلال هذا العمل الفني تشبه تقريبًا
إرسال عمل فني إلى القمر
لإرسال ضوء يمكن أن يسطع
علينا على الأرض ، ويعيد الأموال النقدية الحقيقية
إلى الأرض من
خلال الأموال التي نجمعها
للصناديق الخيرية وإعادتها
إلى الركائز الأربع لشواغلنا الخيرية
التي تساعد في تغيير عالمنا
والمضي قدماً في اهتمامات
الاستدامة
والتثقيف الصحي والمساواة للجميع لأنه إذا  يمكننا
التركيز على تلك المجالات الأربعة التي يمكننا تغيير
عالمنا
[موسيقى]